hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play or back to
let's play the witch's house okay so we
got them lying plants here that we need
to know about birds eat greenery correct
they do so there's some creeping plants
blocking the way and that means that I
need to get some birds I'm guessing
there's some creeping grass here which
means it Hey
oh you were trying to kill me
a big hole with no visible bottom okay
so that's there there's some creeping
grass over there and there's a jail cell
here it's locked
good probably medicine it's locked
someone's moaning inside Oh talk to him
wheeze hack cough medicine you got any I
do not you are spit at well screw you a
metal birdcage open cage door look at it
something feebly flaps its wings do
nothing because I can do nothing now the
red grasses are whispering to each other
but I bet they're all liars liars and
thieves but wasn't one of these like an
important medicine I believe yeah hang
on the red grass is red grasses no hang
on it was yellow flowers yellow flowers
create a strong medicine which is what I
need to get okay I didn't want to read
all I wanted to get out of there thank
you very much don't just don't okay so
now that I'm here and I know all that I
need to I need to get some yellow
flowers what how do I get yellow flowers
that is the question oh hi thank you go
away please okay so where do I get
yellow flowers I thought I remember
seeing something like a Vaz or something
the collapsed woman's statue wasn't
there one in like a Vaz over here it's
actually kind of interesting that I can
backtrack soma so much in these games
but not that far it was like some right
maybe I know I'm a liar
a dirty liar do I still have a key I bet
I don't I don't even know what I have
was in here or anything in here no okay
all right whatever oh man maybe like the
witch is not in crow love that in
control of the house and that's why she
tried to save me there and the which is
like its own who's that
I thought I saw something and like the
witches its own thing that just does
whatever the hell it wants and I'm
trying to survive maybe the cat is the
witch or the house or I don't know what
it is okay it's like a I don't know
beautiful flower white flower beautiful
very beautiful here mr. tree can you do
something for me please
oh that's right I must warn you do not
disturb the keeper of time okay thank
you
all right that's helpful advice because
I got killed by the clock now I need to
figure out how oh the yellow flowers are
right here I'm such an idiot I knew I
found him somewhere they were right here
honestly she's such a nuisance to think
without how we would be the most
beautiful in the car I know right
oh my you've got quite big on I know
they even did the whole oh won't
somebody ex that girl if somebody did oh
yes no we share some of our wonderful
pollen no mmm I'm just gonna be here
okay
that way you're leaving think I'm weird
okay look under the table what did I
find there's a skull on the floor goody
goody gumdrops I have a skull good great
and now there's blood on the wall can I
show the skull to these things and be
like hey I killed her no okay maybe not
wouldn't it be easier to thing to X her
with your big great big arms oh it would
okay so they'll share some pollen if I
kill someone just murder someone dead
okay by
cyndago is leaving forever EXO flowers
and you'll die - okie dokie sorry jeez
hey good okay shut up all right so
anyway oh there was did I go in here
yeah I already went in here cuz I read
this diary didn't I not then a girl came
over to play a cute girl with golden
braids who is me that is me and there
are weird holes opening up in the floor
I guess I don't know the houses trying
to get me to fall back down to the
bottom I don't know
oh no it's pitch black in there and I
have a skull but what do I do with said
skull here take a skull you stupid old
tree and maybe if I give the give the
skull to the keeper of time excuse me
mr. keeper of time man letter don't read
okay do not disturb the keeper of time
okay nope nope yeah maybe I'll just not
touch it don't do nothing okay
alright so now that we have a skull and
no idea what to do with it I'm going to
go over here and try to find rhyme or
reason within my own life
maybe if I put the skull in the little
bird cage put the skull and then no not
the letter but the skull and the thing
no okay no no okay okay now these do you
want to know how to EXO flower yes I do
none of the three ways up to X are
proper you should just give up on it
what I forget what exactly way to proper
X is it was either cutting it up or
uprooting it off rooting and plucking
are both proper ways to X I forget exit
cutting her up for rooting it I'll
brooding or plucking or both proper ways
none of the three ways are proper you
should just give up on it
uprooting I'm guessing up rooting for
the yellows huh oh hi
let's go wait now I have two skulls why
do I have two skulls why hole with no
visible bottom maybe I could put the
skulls in there nope okay all right no
apparently not there's a weird thing for
it a little thirteen-year-old girl to
deal with okay whatever anyway carrying
on hello can i X you can IX you so hard
to think without her we would be the
most beautiful of the garden oh no that
doesn't help me stupid flowers I don't
know how to uproot because I don't have
anything to uproot anything with do I
sail line with T and can sweets shelve
lined with your mom and you're facing it
good okay there might be like a skull in
another room I don't know what do i do
what do I do I have no idea because even
if they give me the proper method of
which to do this uprooting I don't know
war how to do it because it's not given
oh how oh okay oh I see I'm fine thanks
okay so I got it it looked a fruit yay
ow right through my chest right through
my chest why why would you murder me
like that why why would you do that okay
let's try another one
ahh pluck look yay the beautiful flower
expired yay I killed it dead hand now
that's mean hang on I'm gonna go I'm
gonna create a separate say for that one
I told you to be silent I will not be
silent
you lost Island me
okay anyway so now hello there
whispering to each other oh wait oh oh
oh that's what the yellow flowers wanted
they wanted me to kill the white flower
and sounds so racist
I heard it I heard of Lee wail I heard
it yay ah ha ha hmm
oh yes here's your phone got the white
powder Sui I got what I needed
who cares about any of the consequences
lady who cares do i I do not screw
yourselves everyone needs to go to hell
except for me talk
I got medicine just need a little please
no not the skull yeah
grabs the bars hey Goomer lied all right
here you go have fun
uh oh wait okay what is he talking about
I don't even know what he means
okay pry open the door pick up the
birdie something invisible left out ah
Dermot okay what is that what does that
all mean red grasses are whispering to
each other
goody goody gumdrops hidden in the
darkness and the darkness of my own soul
you will find an imperceptible reality
of which you do not understand oh wait a
minute hang on I gotta find in the
darkness oh no in the darkness of the
other room that's right okay what's over
here first something not good it got
quiet water is sealed by skulls yes
reach inside that's a great idea there's
a skull inside okay so I got three
skulls now oh I need four but a skull
their face oh gosh how much was it no
way hey my let me look at these skull is
facing frontwards yes it is how about
that huh facing right left right left
front words what does that mean I don't
know everyone should go to hell
I'll leave or pull it nothing happens
okay so I need to put skulls here but in
what orientation how about just all
front oh wait no yes this one needs to
go to the are they repeating patterns
from da no they're not repeating past
from top to bottom but this one should
go to the right yes
how excellent most excellent and this
one should go to the right to the left
to left hand give me that
skull to the left I don't know I don't
know it's probably some other puzzle
that I I can solve that with let me go
find the last skull and then I'll carry
on with this hidden in the darkness but
first let me go up here okay this is
timer why is there timer
why would there be a timer huhai why
would you do that to me why why would
you do that okay I'm saving okay let's
see what's in here hello
sign the hall is poisoned pass with
colourless shoes the dusty or dirty old
dresser nothing is I WI never dude he's
gonna kill I gonna kill me dead I just
got to get in here in search come on
give me my school give me my school take
empty bottle get one more come on come
on come on okay get out of there get in
there okay there's got to be one more
thing right
take skull yes got it okay nailed it
okay nothing in there nothing in there
there's nothing in here
skull sword you got it okay that's fine
I want to I want to get oh wait no hang
on read it okay I got time
there was once a soldier his country had
perished and he had died but he noticed
neither these things in death the
soldier patrolled staring in the centre
of the castle ruins he looked front
right left front right left front right
left front right left okay so I'm still
not in kind of the shirt entirely
certain what order that needs to be in
so
front right left front right left
okay so front right left front right
left
I'm trying to see a pattern here okay so
ah fudge nutters does it even mean okay
so this one would go to the left left
anything happen could it work now pull
it
nothing happens okay so I got these in
the wrong order somehow front right left
front right left front right ah okay I
see they are they're kind of
top-to-bottom pattern not quite though
face front word front okay left no
that's wrong I don't know I don't know
oh I did it right damn it
fudge I died
damn it after I got that I don't
remember what order I put it in or art
oh no this is wrong damn Hey
what the hell died in a skull bastard
okay so this one needs to be I don't
have it oh I thought I saved didn't I
maybe I didn't I'm such a jerk
fudge okay get it was something in here
take the empty bottle okay get the skull
over here got the skull and that was it
okay let's got here
re-read front right left front right
left
four run right left front right left I
think I think the only thing that I did
differently was put this one front
okay skull face I didn't save let me go
back as a please thank you very much
please thank you thank you very much
don't want to die a horrible death no I
do not save there we go in your
okay okay now let's do this go over here
put it front ways and then we'll be on
our merry way
item skull hey friend word got that okay
put that there
pull the lever water rushing cool beans
and then oh thank you yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay cool yeah we're done okay
we're all out of time so let's take a
breather here so done with that for now
it's such a great game I love this game
so much anyway dope thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
ah
you
this is the fifth